ideally one defenseman as a part of each
Trio but that will not be the case today
Thomas hurdle out there from San Jose
put it right on net and it's stopped by
gorv Travis conne from the Philadelphia Flyers
put it out in front for a good chance eluan
American he's from Michigan considered by many
of the favorites to win the vzna trophy here
at the allstar break for a lot of hockey
still to be played here's McKinnon on a
break away he scores Nathan McKennon with the
first goal of this allstar game it comes at
3:24 Colorado guys have done this before that's
marar coming out from behind the net and he lays
a beautiful sawce right onto the tape of McKinnon
who walks in and beats helbach under the glove
quick release quick shot but what a beautiful
pass as the and it's tapate McCrae from Team
McKinnon team McKinnon coached by Rick bonus
of the Winnipeg Jets first time he's been an
All-Star coach at age 69 and there's a goal
that ties it up Boon Jenner the captain of
the Columbus Blue Jackets in his first All-Star
Game in his 11th season in the NHL the hallway
just ran into him and he said he was it's just
so great to be here it's near home he's got a
bunch of his family here and after 11 years in
the leag Boon Jenner gets into the All-Star Game
and he's got a goal and the Columbus captain had
missed 15 with a broken jaw earlier in the year
and that's that's a he'll he'll never forget I
know it's just it's an All-Star Game and all that
but talk with David Quinn the
Sharks coach yesterday he just
raved about hurdle said he's just
f a person as I've ever coached and
having a terrific year on a team
that is obviously in rebuilding
mode here's another breakway in this time of goal
Oliver Bor strand from the Seattle Kraken after
Reinhardt had hit the post then borran gets
another chance and this time he beats brosi
and it's 2-1 and now it's McDavid circling Jeremy
Swan outstanding in the Nets mention his dads here
they're telling us the story Ray Jeremy actually
almost stopped playing hockey as a 16-year-old in
Alaska when he got cut from his team and mnon back
hands one in he has two goals and team McKinnon
takes a 3 to1 lead didn't need much room at all I
know the guys aren't defending the way they would
normally but Leon dry cdle doesn't have a chance
against him and look at the little flip chip over
the shoulder of babros before he bosski thinks
he's going to go wide so before he's going to
get set just a little chip dry Sidle big guns
out there for team McDavid poster knock dry
Sidle McDavid hurdle goes off he's out of gas
here's poog with a great chance and he scores
they finally get one past Jeremy swayan poster
knock the goal and they're down by one with 312
to go more goals in the National Hockey League
than David poock he's got 94 including 61 last
year he Rockets this up over the glove of Jeremy
Swan and a one-on-one Maestro is poster knock
lots of action on TNT and NHL Network this week
as well final 10 seconds net empty and McDavid
scores two goals in the final minute with the net
empty to tie it up nothing San could do on that
one that was poer knock from McDavid this time
it's McDavid from poer knock as he wanders around
the back door capril Caril Capri off standing out
right there he's turn the your guys behind you oh
yeah that guy too late mcdavid's got it in the net
and two goals with a goalie out and you know will
are going to say that's [Applause] his Jeremy Swan
still in net Conor MCD [Applause] [Music] scores
McDavid just Waits so long as you see Swan
inch his way back he loves that quick release
rer again and Sergey babski and babski made
the stop on Sid the Kid still a [Applause]
kid and swam in the [Music] stop dry CLE with a
couple of assists in regulation play McDavid and
po each with a goal and an assist in regulation he
wants to go back around the right leg and swayan
spreads way out to make the stop here's Nate
mckin and backhand deak is a favorite of his
having a remarkable season and a nice stop again
by bobovski oh he's sharp again now posto with a
chance to put it away he [Applause] scores two
goals in the final 32 seconds of Regulation to
tie it and they win it in the shotout Poo gets
his Puck way behind him and he delays and as he
delays he's got two places he can go top glove or
top blocker the goalie's got to wait with him and
pasta makes a perfect shot a goal to make it 3-2
and the winner in shootout that' be a little weird
dynamic Ray when you're Pastor knock and San
teammates in the regular season share a moment